hier sieht der krieg aus
mein name ist paul ronzheimer und ich
berichte seit 2013 regelmäßig aus der
ukraine aus dem krieg und aus der
hauptstadt kiew
seit dem 24
februar hat putin den krieg gegen die
gesamte ukraine begonnen und was seitdem
hier passiert ist erzähle ich in meinem
kriegstag
[Musik]
es gibt einen ausnahmezustand für das
gesamte land der verhängt wurde durch
die worte von putin der das
existenzrecht der ukraine abgesprochen
hat er gesagt hat nur unter bedingungen
sinngemäß können wir überhaupt noch
sprechen da hat er gefordert die
annexion der krim müsse akzeptiert
werden von der ukraine man müsste
neutral sein und die ganze ganze land
müsse dem entmilitarisiert werden das
sind dinge die sie lenski die ukraine
nicht akzeptieren kann und deswegen ist
die stimmung hier im land mittlerweile
so dass viele mit einem krieg rechnen
die große frage ist wo wird dieser große
krieg dem krieg gab es ja schon aber der
große krieg sozusagen ausbrechen
ausschließlich dann hier im donbass in
dem gebiet wo ich gerade stehe wo schon
geschossen wird wir haben vorhin
berichtet aus einem keller der an der
front wurst heftigen beschuss gehabt
aber bedeutet das dass man am ende den
sonders will wladimir putin oder villa
bis nach kiew und das sind die fragen
die sich momentan gefällt stellen einige
tage vor kriegsbeginn reist bild vize
points heime in die ukraine und trifft
dort exklusiv den staatspräsidenten
wolodimir zielinski ich war zwei tage
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
unterwegs wenn man mit no mercy nancy
unterwegs ist dann spürt man zum einen
die anspannung wir waren heute an der
front mit ihm heute morgen hat es da ein
schläge gegeben und sie hat gesagt sie
mir nein ich will da jetzt hin und ich
will zeigen dass ich nicht in panik bin
dass ich bereit bin hier zu stehen und
auch wenn mein land ein risiko
einzugehen also sind wir dann über die
wipfel front gelaufen durch kaputte
zerschossene häuser von lenz geht hat
immer wieder zu mir gesagt das ist was
wir hier verteidigen müssen das ist
etwas was auch europa tun müsste man
konnte ihm sehr sehr genau anmerken dass
er wütend darüber ist er hat es nicht so
gesagt denn er muss auch diplomat sein
in diesen stunden aber das ist
möglicherweise die ruhe vor dem sturm
und immer mehr glauben dass man
möglicherweise eine invasion doch nicht
verhindern kann
stunde null wladimir putin eröffnet den
kriegen seine russischen truppen rücken
in verschiedene teile der ukraine vor
seit heute nacht ist krieg hier in der
ost ukraine ist schon länger krieg aber
natürlich nicht in diesem ausmaß was wir
dort erleben das offizielle russische
truppen auf offizielle ukrainische
truppen treffen das ist etwas was auch
europa seit jahrzehnten nicht gesehen
hat es war vorher vermeintliche kriege
gegen separatisten die hier
stattgefunden haben aber das ist ein
offizieller krieg gerade ein video
gesehen ist ukrainischen präsidenten mit
dem ich noch vor einer woche unterwegs
war genau hier in der region thomas der
dramatisches video aufgenommen hat die
menschen aufgefordert zu hause zu
bleiben die ruhe zu bewahren aber mein
gefühl ist auch wenn hier teilweise die
menschen ganz normal heute morgen zur
arbeit gegangen sind denn sie sind
diesen krieg schon länger gewohnt hier
wo ich stehe da aus zu verdienen aber
die menschen im ganzen land die ist es
schwer dort die nerven zu behalten alle
telefonieren sind am smartphone
versuchen zu erfahren was jetzt wirklich
passiert wie schnell hier die russischen
truppen kommen könnten die ukraine hat
gegen diese truppe am ende mittelfristig
langfristig keine chance auch wenn ziert
ein flugzeug abgeschossen haben wollen
das ist am ende etwas eine überlegene
russische armee man sehen müssen was
passiert wenn truppe reinkommt dann kann
es passieren dass es hier im ganzen land
nochmals zu tun und meine emotionen aber
das zu erleben dass so viele jahre hier
als reporter als ich doch weil ich viele
freunde aber in der ukraine die angst
von mir leben haben
[Musik]
überall im land gibt es explosionen
die menschen haben angst und fliehen aus
den städten paul ronzheimer ist zu
diesem zeitpunkt noch im besonders
umkämpften osten des landes unterwegs
und jetzt schaut her wo wir hingekommen
sind die ukraine sowie sie war so wie
sie ist sie existiert nicht mehr eine
invasion von wladimir putin und schon
wenige stunden ungefähr 13 14 stunden
nach beginn dieser invasion kann man
sagen die ukraine existiert nicht mehr
in ihrer form mehrere städte sind schon
erobert unter anderem eine großstadt im
osten sowie das ist die ecke wo ich
herkam wir sind ihr stunden unterwegs in
diesem auto auf ja kaputten wegen sind
immer wieder im stau weil alle leute
sondern viele leute hier richtung westen
überall kommt es zu langen staus auf den
ausfallstraßen
die bombardierung der städte zwingt die
menschen unter die erde dorthin wo es
vermeintlich sicherer ist ab jetzt
findet das leben unter tage statt in
kellern bunkern und u-bahnhöfen und
man ist hier hoch dann sehen hier die
geisterhaft lichkeiten zitiert
mittlerweile ausstrahlt es ist abends
die stadt wartet darauf dass es ein 9
bombenangriff geben könnte das ist
normalerweise hier der beliebteste platz
den es im camp gibt der berühmte mal da
dass es der platz wo 2014 die
demonstration stattgefunden haben
hunderttausende menschen die hilfe an
und jetzt schau dich um eine
geisterstadt wir sehen hier immer wieder
eine böse stimmung auch auf diesem platz
immer wieder polizei die hier in diese
richtung kommt gerade leute kontrolliert
ich nehme euch nochmal mit das ist immer
die große angst dass jederzeit hier eine
provokation losgehen könnte also
jederzeit russische truppen hier in
irgendwelcher form spezialeinheiten auch
auf diesen platz kommen weil er
natürlich eine historische dimension hat
man davon ausgeht dass wenn russland
hier einnehmen sollte wenn die russische
armee griff einnehmen sollte dass das
eines der zentralen plätze sein wird von
wladimir putin verhasst dieser meiden
weil er für alles steht was mit wladimir
putin hat nämlich demokratie und
freiheit er hat ja von nazis gesprochen
die ich hier regieren und wir müssen
jetzt einmal wieder schauen was dort los
ist gerade die polizei die wieder autos
kontrolliert ja also eine aufgeladene
stimmung hier am ball war und wo wir
jetzt kaum noch einen menschen sehen
die lage in der ukrainischen hauptstadt
spitzt sich an diesem tag weiter zu
im zentrum von kiew ist deutlich
artilleriebeschuss zu hören und obwohl
russland immer behauptet keine angriffe
auf die zivilbevölkerung zu fahren wird
ein buch haus im zentrum kiews getroffen
die russische armee das gebäude hier
eines der größten hochhäuser im tier
attackiert und wie die menschen thomas
hat das natürlich auch etwas
symbolisches ist als erste wirkliche
riesen hochhaus dass sie getroffen wurde
ihr direkt auf einer viel befahrenen
ukrainischen käfer strafte die
polizisten und die armee ist noch
wahnsinnig nervös hier an der position
wir wurden gerade mit angezogener waffe
angehalten man hat wahnsinnige angst
davor dass hier ein weiterer angriff
passieren könnte wir sehen dort
und es ist interessant intesa wir sind
am besten ganz dahinten in eine kleine
natürlich von polizei und armee
und wenn wir uns hier umschauen trotz
dann muss man sagen ist das tatsächlich
ein horrorszenario
wenn wir die nächsten stunden oder tage
betrachten wenn weitere russische
raketen ihr auch die viele häuser fallen
sollten dann könnte ist eine hohe anzahl
von opfern in vier geben bei ähnlichen
angriffen aber weil sie mit kleinerem
ausmaß klar in den vergangenen tagen des
menschen im bunker waren zum teil kann
nur hoffen dass das in diesem hause war
trotz dieser angriffe befindet sich aber
weiter in der hand der regierung
versichert bürgermeister vitali
klitschko es gebe allerdings 35
verletzte darunter zwei kinder auch im
süden der ukraine wird weiter gekämpft
besonders heftig sind die angriffe auf
die hafenstädte odessa und mario co
[Musik]
die russen liefern sich weiterhin harte
gefechte mit der ukraine und stoßen
dabei auf unerwartet heftigen widerstand
inzwischen befinden sich bereits mehr
als 40 der russischen invasionstruppen
also etwa 150.000 soldaten in der
ukraine für die geht es in den nächsten
tagen um die nationale existenz deshalb
werden die ukrainischen rufe nach
internationalen waffenlieferungen immer
lauter
das bedeutet dass deutschland bitter die
jetzt erstmals brachte sie also dass
oder im angekündigt hat das stück zum
die deutsche ist eine regel bundestag
des bundeskanzlers olaf scholz
monatelang platte
unterstützung bevor
er geht nicht das ist hier wirklich die
ganze demokratische welt das ist eine
kleine
ich habe während die chance uns geboren
weil
lang hält auch wie die großen
die neuesten opferzahlen des
ukrainischen
gesundheitsministeriums besagen über 350
zivilisten getötet die zahl der
verletzten geht in die tausende
das schicksal einer verletzten der
dreifachen mutter ihrer geht bild vize
pforzheimer besonders nach erst dann
abend hat mich praktisch wurde bruder
von vitali der diese ihr auto der
familie den mann kannte darüber
informiert dass ihre gestern nachmittag
von einer explosion auf der straße
schwer verletzt wurde lebensgefährlich
verletzt wurde sie liegt im krankenhaus
ihr gesicht wurde entstellt es ist
unklar ob es ein unfall war oder ob am
ende ist möglicherweise ein
direkter angriff war weil sie dort eben
mit gegen putin
demonstriert hat davon die meisten
beobachter gehen nicht aus dennoch eine
dramatische situation und man sieht
daran dass es hier sehr wohl zivilisten
trifft und eben nicht nur wie gesagt
wird das ukrainische militär
[Musik]
der unmenschliche krieg von wladimir
putin bewegt die menschen auf der ganzen
welt in berlin sind 20.000 demonstranten
angemeldet am ende wird es etwa eine
halbe million
hätten wir das ganze vor so viel
so vielen wochen monaten jahren gewöhnt
dass endlich ein klares signal gibt auch
insbesondere vom linken politischen
zentrum in richtung zu ziehen das ist
jetzt passiert rührt mich fast an
wenigen ein rhythmisch tatsächlich und
ich glaube es ist genau das richtige
zeichen hierfür die menschen die hier
kessel von hier
fand haben müssen die von den waffen von
wladimir putin ermordet zu werden
jetzt gibt es ein bisschen hoffnung ihre
hinderten sie hat es mit internationalen
hilfe und diesem flugzeug raus geschafft
aus dem kriegsland aus der kriegs
hauptstadt kiew sie ist er gelandet in
düsseldorf bilder der hoffnung dort
unterstützt von notärzten die
bundespolizei jahren geholfen und sie
wird jetzt sie sehen sich hier auf der
trage beim
transporter neben den rettungswagen sie
wird jetzt versorgt
intensivmedizinisch in der essener
uniklinik alles gute
[Musik]
am morgen des fünften tages wird
sichtbar was in der zweitgrössten
ostukrainischen stadt charkiw geschehen
ist einer der blutigsten anschläge seit
kriegsbeginn
die bilder reden
einen direkten angriff vor 3 stunden auf
die stadt kalkar was im nordosten der
ukraine wie sie befinden
und das sind schreckliche bilder
diesen zivilisten die in ihren gebeten
mit hofstaat den häusern
explosionen sieht man sie tötet
oppermann sieht
gestorbenen babys
man sie zivilisten die sterben um
sinnlos
attackiert bombardiert die bilder sind
das wahre gesicht dieses krieges es ist
nur
das böse
was jetzt aus russland kommt das böse
was uns ukraine tötet
mindestens 21 menschen sterben bei dem
angriff über 100 werden verletzt wieder
sind das zivile gebäude die gezielt
angegriffen werden wieder ist es die
bevölkerung die unter putins brutaler
gewalt leidet
machen ist gestern das mache hat nicht
alle tassen schafft jeder
hasst booten jede ist sehr sehr
patriotisch für die reine und so viele
leute ständig mein telefon ist richtig
schon heiß von anrufen leute fragen der
wollen waffen wir wollen unserem land
verteidigen unsere stadt italien leute
ist sehr gut gestern abend nun wieder
mit meiner kleinen gesprochen mit
kleinste
weil es schon nicht mehr gleich als 16
weil 17 aber
wenig zeit sogar sogar mit mit kindern
zu sprechen und alle haben so geschickt
in der sms das habe ich auch die ist
papa pass auf dich auf sagen die kinder
von vitali klitschko in diesen tagen
vielen dank
die schlinge zieht sich immer weiter zu
inzwischen ist die versorgung der
menschen mit lebensmitteln kaum noch
gewährleistet so sieht es hier
die menschen die in der stadt geblieben
sind die versorgen sich hier noch mit
dem nötigsten
lange
versucht sich einzudecken
hier mit den lebensmitteln weil sie
nicht wissen was in den nächsten stunden
in den nächsten tagen auf sie zukommen
am dienstag brennt ein wahrzeichen der
fernsehturm von kiew ist getroffen
stürzt aber nicht ein ein symbolischer
treffer mitten ins herz der stadt
das ist der fernsehturm es schneit es
ist eine düstere atmosphäre kaum licht
dass ihr ein test aber
bis gestern zum symbol des angriffs
geworden hier auf die hauptstadt der tv
tower ist nicht komplett zerstört
jahrescharts nichts wir sehen hier wie
es aber noch mal hört man riecht
sozusagen immer noch sind schwarz dieses
anschlags ausstehend und man muss davon
ausgehen dass rösler es noch mal
versuchen wir hier ein völlig zerstörtes
auto ich schaue da einmal sein das
passiert wenn man hier eine rakete ab
bekommt das auto komplett zerstört auf
dem boden und wenn wir hier weiter gehen
dann sieht man all die setzte der
zerstört wo wir von dem anschlag auf den
tv dahinten braucht es noch wir sehen
hier die rettungskräfte dort vorstehen
der rauch des krieges
mitten in kiew das sind
bedrückende bilder
die wir hier erleben in einer stadt die
schlage käme die ich liebe und die gäste
angegriffen wird
die brutale wahrheit des krieges wird an
diesem tag besonders deutlich in einem
krankenhaus keller erlebt paul
unglaubliches
dieser krieg hat dazu geführt dass die
menschen dann wenn das alarm gibt hier
unten in den keller flüchtet man sich
hier die rohre die hier verlaufen und
die patienten sind untergebracht in
diesen zimmern joggers
film endlich hier sieht man wie
patienten warten wir sehen kleine babys
die hier sind kleine babys untergebracht
in diesem bunker heute alleine heute
sind sechs babys geboren wurden ein
neues leben in einer
situation die
schwer zu beschreiben ist weil es für
die menschen hier so schwierig ist wenn
wir uns den krieg anschauen und was
draußen auf den straßen los ist
der moment im krankenhaus ging auch
deshalb dar weil ich dort mein
fotografen in new york des motivs
gesehen habe der selbst vater geworden
ist kurz bevor er hier mit mir in die
ukraine gefahren und mehrheit ist
weggefahren hat seine tochter eine woche
alt war und sie ist mittlerweile
fünf wochen alt und er sagte zu mir was
ihnen das wie sehr ihn das bewegt hat
weil er hat dass babys zur welt kommen
in einer sicheren situation in athen und
in einer lage wo eine normale klinik
hatte aber nicht so ein keller
doch die brutalität des krieges schafft
erstaunliches die ukraine rücken noch
enger zusammen
ihr wille anscheinend unbändig wladimir
man hat das gefühl so grausam dieser
krieg ist so viele opfer es gibt dass es
im land dafür sorgt dass der
zusammenhalt noch stärker wir in der
ukraine und der patriotismus und der
wille dieses land auch zu verteidigen
wie nimmst du das war ich bin stolz
ich bin stolz
ich glaube
jetzt die
ganze welt
aber gleichzeitig sagt die welt auch wir
schicken euch waffen wir schicken euch
hilfe aber militärisch seid ihr auf euch
allein gestellt
das verstehen ja
es gibt gewalt
letztendlich ist es zu hause
wo die eltern arm begraben sind in den
schulen gehen
leider sind bauen kinder wenn zivilisten
denn sie den schon gekippt
schwere luftangriffe auf kiew und fragte
mehrere explosionen der feind versucht
in die hauptstadt durch zu brechen sagt
kiews bürgermeister vitali klitschko an
diesem tag trifft paul ronzheimer den
ukrainischen präsidenten zum interview
was mein eigenes leben betrifft ich als
präsident dieses landes habe kein recht
angst zu haben und meine seele schmerzt
auch und ich mache mir sorgen um meine
verwandten und wir haben alle unser
leben in den ort wo wir leben zu
verlieren ich habe angst mir
vorzustellen dass ich kein land mehr
habe und wenn man fragt wo kommst du her
und du sagst solches land gibt es nicht
mehr die vor sowas habe ich angst ich
habe angst was wir unsere nächsten
generation überlassen
und was die ganze welt betrifft die welt
soll wissen genauso wie herr scholz
beiden marken dass wir schon mehrmals
angesprochen haben dass es uns sehr
wichtig ist sicherheitsgarantien zu
haben das alles passiert jetzt und das
habe ich schon vorher ehrlich über die
nato gesagt wenn ihr eure eigene union
eure länder der allianz nicht schützt
mit sanktionen mit harten antworten auf
bedrohungen
es wird sie nicht mehr geben die
verlangen dass wir unsere waffen
niederlegen aufgeben zu kämpfen die
annexion unseres territoriums
akzeptieren was soll weiter passieren
die catenaccio
das lief sehr interessant ab auch etwas
unheimlich fast kann man sagen dass ich
hab heute morgen eine whatsapp nachricht
bekommen bitte finden sie sich dann und
dann an diesen check point ein es geht
aber unter ihren eigenen risiko wir
können nicht für ihren schutz
versprechen und dann ging es weiter mit
einer gruppe einzelner journalisten dann
in dieses präsidenten gebäude war schon
häufiger ich habe dort prosecco
interview zielinski kaputt aber immer in
friedenszeiten als ich da rein bin ich
habe es nicht mehr wieder erkannt das
licht war ausgeschaltet ich bin dann
dadurch habe über als sandsäcke gesehen
an den verschiedenen seiten unheimlich
das muss man sich mal vorstellen so als
würde man zu einem interview so olaf
scholz gehen und alle dichter sind
ausgeschaltet und man läuft durch einen
raum und fliegt fast auf die nase weil
man über die treppen läuft also eine
völlig absurde situation auch dann sind
wir dort in diesem presseraum gegangen
der sei wiederum normal aus andere
allerdings wurde er natürlich geschützt
von schwerbewaffneten ukrainischen
soldaten und hat mir kurz werden kurz
die hand geschüttelt weil wir uns kennen
und dann hat er losgelegt sehr entspannt
tatsächlich trotz dieses wahnsinnigen
druck
[Musik]
an diesem tag ein weiterer tiefpunkt bei
kämpfen nahe europas größtem
atomkraftwerk im süden der ukraine ist
in der nacht zu freitag ein feuer
ausgebrochen
gleichzeitig erreicht die fluchtwelle
der ukraine einen neuen höhepunkt der
hauptbahnhof überschwemmt von
ängstlichen hauptstädte
[Musik]
das ist die treppe wo die menschen durch
kommen hier und das ist tatsächlich wir
sehen wieder sehr sehr viele kinder wir
sind viele
frauen ihre haustiere mitbringen
dies beginne
[Musik]
für sie könnte sie also eine zeigen am
rhein das ist der platz wo die menschen
hin wollen
nein er ist leichter hoffnung kann man
es denn das gleis was in den frieden
führt zumindest jetzt ist dort noch
bieten um die frauen viele frauen und
kinder wie hier sind und die bereit sind
ihr land erst einmal oder ihre stadt
erst einmal zu verlassen aber die sagen
mir hier wir sind bereit wieder zu
kommen aus kiew rauskommen diese frage
stellen wir uns natürlich auch hinten
tag beobachten das genau wie sich der
kessel zu schließt wir beraten uns noch
mit sicherheitsexperten nach über was
dann der beste weg aus es noch gibt es
züge die nach lemberger richtung westen
gehen viele nehmen aber auch das auto
also noch ist das alles möglich aber wir
werden natürlich unsere sicherheitslage
und die frage wie wir berichten können
immer noch jeden tag neu
ich war da wurden 14 tagen und sofern
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten in den
straßen unterwegs alles noch mal eine
wirklich große standorte osten und jetzt
verwüstet eingekesselt allerdings muss
man sagen neben der frage was vollkommen
richtig und wichtig ist dass die
wenigsten dort rauskommen kann man sich
auch dort die frage stellen wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass die russische armee
bislang diese standen auch nicht
eingenommen hat also wir müssen uns ja
immer wieder klar machen am tag zehn des
krieges tag lief eine großstadt im osten
ist nicht eingenommen und jetzt eine
großstadt ist nicht eingenommen und
marion puhle auch nicht also die einzige
größere stadt die die russische armee
bislang angenommen hat ist er soll aber
von diesen symbolhaft stimmen hat die
russische armee weiterhin keine komplett
unter ihre kontrolle
es kann tage wochen monate dauern aber
irgendwann werden die russischen truppen
hier einrollen
ich bin wieder an einem geheimen ort
unterwegs mit dem krupp oder um zu
verstehen wie tierfellen fällt die
beiden sind kämpferisch die beiden sind
weiter fest gewählt natürlich hier zu
bleiben natürlich alles zu tun um tiere
zu verteidigen und sie sind wirklich
immer zusammen dass ich schon auch
gleichzeitig die hürden zu sehen die
beiden großen brüder einst zusammen
immer im boxring und jetzt zusammen hier
kriegt ihr
vitali klitschko
der bürgermeister von kiew ist
unermüdlich im einsatz für seine stadt
rock sagt doktor eisenfaust genannt
verstimmt
eisenfaust und preise statt das ist man
von selbstbehalten aus doktor eisenfaust
wird jetzt der bürgermeister eine
eisenstadt
wir malen was
ich mache das von unserer stadt
weißensee button ich jetzt ein trio alle
sind fans von unsere stadt eisenstadt zu
machen
[Musik]
und auch das gibt es trotz oder gerade
weil krieg herrscht der bund fürs leben
geschlossen
direkt hinter den frontlinien
der freude die menschen auch wenn die
camouflage betragen haben auch wenn sie
wachten getragen haben diesen krieg
irgendwie vergessen konnten für ein paar
minuten war auch zu dem zeitpunkt kein
beschuss also man hat keine artillerie
man hat keine gefechte gehören sondern
man hat sich auf diese beiden menschen
konzentriert sich vorher natürlich nicht
kannte aber sich dann dort erlebt haben
und dann dieses glück zu sehen der
beiden das dann aber im nächsten moment
auch wieder umgeschwenkt ist als nicht
mit ihr darüber gesprochen habe was sie
sonst nacht im leben sie arbeitet mit
kindern hat sie mir berichtet ist mit
ihrem mann zusammen eben diese zivile
verteidigungs einheit gegangen das sind
hunderttausende in der ganzen ukraine
die dort an checkpoints an der front
sich freiwillig gemeldet haben
vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder
andere noch kurz vor dem krieg da war
auch ich hier im januar und da sind sie
über sandplätze gerannt mit holz waffen
und in deutschland haben die leute
gedacht menschen die verrückt sind die
denn das wird doch eh nicht passiert
dass ihr krieg ausbricht und wie sollen
sie sich dann verteidigen ja und jetzt
ist es ernst und jetzt stehen diese ganz
normalen menschen die vorher lehrer
künstler arbeiter was auch immer waren
stehen dort und verteidigen mit irland
und dann dieser moment der hochzeit nach
orthodoxer tradition dann wurde die
nationalhymne gesungen und ja es war ein
kurzer moment des glücks auch wladimir
klitschko findet das normale leben muss
weiter stattfinden so gut es eben geht
infrastruktur und mächtigen leben aber
hier entsteht wahrscheinlich so auslegen
dass
das ist ja wichtig in diesen tagen und
dann wir haben ein gute laune haben
wichtig in diesen tagen jetzt so kurzer
zeit eine eine pause von vorschüssen
diskussionen und
jede
gewalttat die man dann in den
vergangenen tagen zehn tagen die
vergangene welt zu sehen
die beiden bleiben in bayern an das sind
wir der gleichen verteidigungs einheit
in der wo wir sie besucht haben für sie
ist es schon schwierig genug deshalb
sehr mir auch dort berichtet dass diese
kinder alle wechselt der eine 18 jährige
tochter und für die was besonders
schweren dass ich nicht da war jetzt an
diesem besonderen tag sie haben diese
hochzeit schon länger geplant und hatten
sie tatsächlich auch auf diesen tag
terminiert aber vor dem krieg hatten sie
das geplante und sie wussten natürlich
nicht dass an dem tag erleben sie
heiraten würde der krieg längst da ist
aber dann haben sie gesagt nein das
werden wir putin jetzt nicht aufgeben
wir werden nicht mit unserer hochzeit
streicht wladimir putin krieg gegen uns
wird und dann haben wir diese zeremonie
heute gesendet
das leben geht weiter
das leben geht weiter und wir werden
überleben
wir werden gewinnen
wir verteidigen unsere land und unsere
prinzipien
da gibt es keine frage
und dann erreichen uns wieder
schreckliche bilder
diesmal vor allem aus in einer vorstadt
von kiew und der dauerbeschuss
wir sehen ja an einer brücke letzten die
gerade aus der stadt gekommen sind und
jetzt sozusagen wieder
sicherheit sind zumindest in der
scheinbaren sicherheit natürlich kann
auch hier wieder zeit eine rakete ein
treffen das ist sozusagen der weg
richtung ihr team nur drei kilometer
ungefähr von hier drei bis vier
kilometer da geht es auf diesen platz
und das war die schlacht das waren die
bilder die ihr gesehen habt foren wo
diese rakete eingeschlagen ist wo
zivilisten ums leben gekommen sind
natürlich macht es einem wenn man so
viel angst wenn man die zerstörten
häuser sieht wenn man die raketen
gesehen der titel eingeschlagen sind und
wie schnell das gehen kann das haben wir
ein team gesehen wo eine kollegin filmt
hat die daneben stand wie die rakete
oder zivilisten betroffen
wir sehen jetzt hier hinter mir zb wie
einer busse rauskommt wir hören im
hintergrund auch artillerie ein bisschen
weiter weg und mit diesen bussen werden
jetzt die leute hier raus gebracht wir
hören im hintergrund einschläge ich weiß
nicht ob ihr es scheint aber wir sehen
hier völlig erschöpfte menschen die ihre
habseligkeiten mitgebracht haben und
vielleicht können wir hier einmal
von hier weiter gebracht werden nachts
ihr zusammengekauert in diesen bus
menschen die gerade aus eppingen
gekommen sind
es ist
also russische panzer in der nähe der
zivilen
häuserkampf hat gestoppt
als er sagt die greifen die russische
armee greift zivilisten an wir gehen ja
einmal durch diesen bus um zu zeigen
welche menschen herausgekommen sind aus
op das sind die überlebenden
ausrangierte klubs kein mini gesagt wir
müssen diesen wir müssen endlich diesen
den luftraum schließen damit die
menschen raus kommen hollande die pr
inside.com große bombe lange
bombing und wie herbie
ausnahmen sein haus ist
also aus das haus sieht
ein großes hochhaus 88 stockwerke
komplett zerstört die menschen in ihr
wenig gras und wasser brauchen wir die
ziehen müssen versorgt werden er sagt
dort ist alles zusammengebrochen
wir sehen wie weitere busse
[Musik]
in diese richtung fahren ich zeige euch
jetzt noch mal wo ist sozusagen langgeht
beginnt einmal gelang
wir sehen auch kranken waren also die
fahren jetzt weiter immer wieder in
diese richtung von da wo die busse
fahren und holen dort weitere menschen
draußen sind noch tausende wie weiter
eingeschlossen
unter den toten und verletzten sind
mehrere kinder alte menschen in den
straßen liegen über 1200 leichen noch
immer harren viele verängstigte bürger
in der 80.000 einwohner stadt aus wir
sind an dem platz einem vorort von port
wo gestern mehrere zivilisten von einer
rakete getroffen worden hinter mir eine
kirche die fast völlig ordentlich wir
ein auto und da sieht man die kraft
[Musik]
wenn wir die einschläge sehen und immer
noch wie das donnergrollen in erp diesem
vorort der halle geworden ist bei putins
krieg und dann wir hier in diese
richtung gehen
die halle aus der halle zu viel aber sie
wurden vorher von den raketen getroffen
man kann sich vorstellen
was das bedeutet wenn weitere raketen
hier auf diesem vor ort und auch hier
fallen
gibt es überhaupt kein handynetz mehr
alles ausgefallen sein elektrizität die
menschen versuchen verzweifelt
raus
gibt es gerade ein kurzes zeitfenster
das ist kehrt das ist putins kriegen das
ist hier der vor ort
wir haben keinen bodyguard der uns hier
in der ukraine begleitet das bringt aus
meiner sicht auch wenig denn die gefahr
besteht darin dass man von aktiven der
bestimmt und desto kleiner das team ist
desto besser ist es am ende auch aus
sicherheitsgründen also wir sind
unterwegs mit einem ukrainischen
übersetzer einem fahrer naja was soll
mir dass es eine situation die wir in
allen kriegst du krisengebieten die wir
bereist haben immer so machen denn das
ist am ende für uns einfacher als mit
einem großen team führen bodyguards die
am ende auch nichts verändern können in
der frage ob tatsächlich eine rakete
irgendwo einschlagen kann oder nicht das
versuchen wir mit unserer erfahrung
selbst zu koordinieren
[Musik]
abschied von papa sogar dieser kleine
junge versteht schon warum sein vater
helm und uniform trägt und was das für
die familie bedeutet
[Musik]
nur sechs stunden zeit haben die
bewohner ihr zuhause zu verlassen
solange soll hier eine waffenruhe
herrschen aber keiner kann ihnen
garantieren dass die russen nicht doch
weiter schießen nach der kurzen
feuerpause allen sie die stadt endgültig
einigen
wie schnell kann dann auch die wenige
kilometer entfernte hauptstadt fallen
will paul ronzheimer vom bürgermeister
wissen
[Musik]
man könnten die soldaten die russischen
soldaten hier sei niemals niemals die
kommen niemals was des stadtstaates
nicht nur gebäude statt dass es die
leute wäre war legten die letten die
stadt und ich möchte eine salon so eine
riesige party is well ist noch nie
gewesen wenn du keine ich treffe
verschiedene leute auf der straße alle
hass und russische aggression alle alle
wollen und jede hat eine riesige will
und wunsch unserer stadt zuständig
ukrainische zivilisten lehnen sich gegen
den krieg auf mit unglaublichem mut
konfrontieren sie die bewaffneten
russischen soldaten dann fallen schüsse
direkt in die menge
den mut die invasoren zurückzutreiben
bezahlen einige mit dem leben
die ukraine auch die ganz normalen
bürger kämpfen trotzdem weiter um jeden
meter
sie können normale zivilisten sich gegen
eine russische armee jetzt unterstützt
wir konnte chemischen kämpfer die hoch
ausgebildet ist die technisches gerät
deswegen dass wegen nicht nur für alle
bedanken wir uns lokale unterstützung
ohne unsere ohne unsere freunde und das
tue so vondra und beliebt seit langer
zeit nicht mehr gegen
russische norddeutschland wie können wir
nicht untätig und nicht nur eine wir
verteidigen werden wir
verteidigen die
prinzipien und
wo endet die interessen die ruß und das
ist in den ersten games oder geräts in
holland oder grill deutsche grenze oder
vielleicht eine gute idee hat butt
ehemalige ddr wieder aufzubauen dass es
wissen und gewissen
über zwei millionen menschen sind
bereits geflohen nach polen nach
rumänien nach deutschland
[Musik]
die bilder dieses kleinen jungen bewegen
die ganze welt
der vierjährige läuft offenbar ganz
alleine über einen grenzübergang nach
polen
es ist niemand zu sehen der sich um ihn
kümmert doch es gibt eine gute nachricht
wie der polnische grenzschutz mitteilt
hat der kleine valerie seine familie
inzwischen wiedergefunden
ich will euch einmal ihr die deutsche
botschaft zeigen weil ist auch etwas
symbolisches gibt hier hinter mir ist
ein teil der berliner mauer zu sehen der
hier in der botschaft aufgestellt wurde
und es gibt immer größere debatten
darüber wo man sozusagen die ukraine in
der zukunft aussehen könnte nämlich die
frage die sich immer mehr menschen hier
stellen ist gibt es eine teilung des
landes geben nach einem krieg denn der
druck von wladimir putin wird größer in
diesem moment wir gehen hier einmal
weiter durch vielleicht einfach nur
dieses botschaftsgebäude völlig verwaist
mittlerweile wir sehen hier das war der
bundesrepublik und hier sehen wir die
aussage der deutschen botschaft dass die
botschaft vorübergehend geschlossen ist
und die evakuierung eben passiert ist
aber noch einmal zurück mit der frage
was sozusagen gerade bei den
kriegshandlungen passiert wir müssen
darüber sprechen wie sozusagen die
debatte läuft in der ukrainischen
politik höre von verschiedenen quellen
dass der druck von der militärische
druck sowohl aus dem süden wir hören
auch am asowschen meer gibt es massive
was militärischen druck und die debatten
werden geführt ob es am ende so zu sagen
ja zu einer verhandlungslösung doch in
irgendeiner form kommt dann muss er
zusammenfassen nicht einmal aktiv also
im osten oder mario obwohl wir diese
schrecklichen angriffe gesehen habe
konnte die russische armee bislang
einnehmen und noch gar nicht gesprächen
über die hauptstadt und dann ist er die
frage was bedeutet ist am ende eine
stadt zu kontrollieren hier hat
normalerweise fast vier millionen
einwohner bei sind noch hier ist eine
riesen metropole genauso wie vor aktiv
und andere das heißt man müsste ja
dauerhaft hunderttausende soldaten hier
in verschiedenen städten haben wenn man
davon wenn man sieht wie groß der
widerstand ist deswegen ist die große
frage wie er sich das ganze ursprünglich
vorgestellt hatte offenbar sowie auf der
krim 2010 das ukrainische soldaten die
waffen niederlegen und an was sagen ja
wir wollen zu russland gehören aber das
gegenteil ist der fall und das macht es
für ihn so kompliziert die angriffe auf
mario pohl von denen paul ronzheimer
spricht treffen an diesem tag ein
kinderkrankenhaus mit geburtsklinik
besonders hart drei tote darunter ein
kind dazu zahlreiche verletzte darunter
viele hochschwangere frauen putins armee
schreckt offenbar vor nichts zurück und
hinterlässt hier im osten des landes
unermessliches leid und elend
[Musik]
bild vize paul ronzheimer hat an diesem
abend noch einen besonderen termin er
ist an einem geheimen ort zum
exklusiv-interview mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten sie lenski verabredet mit
dem man den inzwischen die halbe welt
bewirbt
haben sie angst dass kiew umschlossen
wird
ich habe keine angst wovor auch ich darf
keine angst haben ich bleibe ruhig
wissen sie wie jemand seine angst
überwinden kann was kann schlimmer sein
als angst was ist das schlimmste was
passieren könnte mit ihrem land mit
meinem land das schlimmste was passieren
könnte ist schon passiert wir haben
einen krieg russland gegen die ukraine
es sind so viele menschen jetzt gefallen
das land wurde zerstört was könnte
schlimmeres passieren für die menschen
die ihre kinder verloren haben wir
glauben an die zukunft wir werden nicht
aufgeben wir werden unser land nicht
es war ein treffen dass man nur schwer
beschreiben kann denn es ist ein treffen
in einem präsidentenpalast im krieg man
kommt dort rein es gibt endlich mehr ich
bin fast erneut über eine treppe
gestolpert weil ich das gar nicht sehen
konnte wo ich dort lang gelaufen bin
dann auf diesem platz hat in einer
berater gesagt war sie hier und um uns
herum sandsäcke und man denkt der
angriff hier passiert ja jetzt passiert
er gleich was passiert hier gerade und
dann wartet man und wartet man und
plötzlich kommt bloß selensky um die
ecke wolle jetzt spannend und fragte
interview bist du bei uns im audio ports
und fragt mich wie ich mich in kiew zu
recht fühle und man denkt wahnsinn wie
macht der mann das seit mehr als zwei
wochen im krieg und dennoch ist er
zumindest nach außen hin relativ
entspannt der wahre wert des lebens ist
das leben selbst und dass du nicht
ermordet
und das muss europa tun das einfache
leben verteidigen und auch die wahren
werte auf den ersten platz stellen und
ich wünsche ihnen dass ihre priorität im
leben die wahren werte bleiben aber das
was jetzt bei uns passiert das könnte
auch ihnen passieren
und das ist mir ganz besonders wichtig
wir sterben auch für sie
das interview vorbei war wollte
eigentlich noch auf der treppe sitzen
bleiben und wir haben weiter diskutiert
über die lage wollte von mir wissen was
in deutschland diskutiert wird auch wie
die politische situation ist und hat
auch mich und meine meinung gefragt was
ich glaube warum der westen keine
flugverbotszone will bzw
warum sie nicht schneller diese
unterstützung bekommen weil merkt bei
bludenz geht das er dringend darauf
setzt dass aus dem westen mehr
unterstützung kommt das sicherlich auch
ein grund warum ich dieses interview
bekommen habe natürlich will er im
westen in europa weiter die leute
aufwecken kommunikation ist für ihn in
diesem krieg das entscheidende um sich
abzusetzen von wladimir putin
während die verhandlungen der
außenminister scheitern müssten die
ukraine sich gegen weitere angriffe und
schützen ihre kulturschätze es gibt
keine aussicht auf waffenruhe ich gehe
davon aus das hat sich auch in meinen
gesprächen ergeben dass es weitere
versuche der russischen armee gibt
insbesondere in den vororten wir haben
den vergangenen tagen viel über ihre pin
und guter gesprochen das sind die orte
wo es heftige kämpfe gibt und aus allen
seiten wird versucht weiter richtung
hier vor zu kommen und hier die wege
abzuschneiden möglicherweise könnte sich
das ganze weiter eskaliert durch die
tatsache dass es keine aufgabe der
ukraine bislang gibt und auch keine
ergebnisse bei den diskutierten
friedensverhandlungen
aber auch die rückschläge für die
russische armee werden immer greifbarer
das ukrainische verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlicht diese bilder sie zeigen
wie geschosse einen russischen
militärkonvoi bombardieren und mehrere
panzer zerstören
ein neuer tag ein neuer angriff diesmal
auf die millionenstadt die niepel sie
war bisher verschont geblieben jetzt
gibt es auch hier wie jetzt in opfer es
werden nicht die letzten gewesen sein
die strategie der ukraine momentan
bedeutet sie brauchen schnell
insbesondere
raketenabwehr flugabwehr damit der
russische vormarsch weiterhin verzögert
werden kann und die verhandlungsposition
der ukraine denn irgendwann wird es
verhandlungen geben müssen gut bleibt
bzw besser wird das ist das was die
ukraine wollen sie sagen das kommt auf
jede minute an es kommt auf jeden tag an
und deswegen ist man natürlich hier
bereit auch die waffen so schnell wie
möglich an die plätze zu bekommen an
denen sie gebraucht werden insbesondere
rund um mario pohl insbesondere rund um
kiew wo weiterhin davon auszugehen ist
dass die russische armee eine
einkesselung versuchen wird große sorge
hat man hier in der ukraine davor dass
jetzt auch tschetschenische kämpfer
weitere tschetschenische kämpfer kommen
könnten und aufruf von wladimir putin
heute bei einer sitzung des
sicherheitsrats dort in russland dass
man assad kämpfern also syrischen
soldaten ermöglichen will hier in die
ukraine zu kommen und an der seite von
russland zu kämpfen ich glaube es ist
sehr schwer da voraussagen zu treffen
weil die ukrainische armee immer wieder
überrascht hat immer wieder gezeigt hat
dass sie obwohl sie in der minderheit
ist aber ausgestattet mit westlichen
waffen hier immer wieder für
überraschungen sorgen kann insofern als
dass man das land besser verteidigt als
es viele erwartet hatten
die ukraine aus der luft jeden tag das
land mehr und mehr vom krieg gezeichnet
[Musik]
ein außenbezirk in kiel wenige kilometer
hinter der frontlinie zivilisten haben
eine versorgungsstation für die
ukrainische armee errichtet
soldaten und von ihr dort gelieferten an
die front die nicht beide sind das ist
so auf unseren hier ein sänger ein
ukrainischer sänger hören einfach mal
rein
das sind momente live aus kehrt thomas
leif portiert und das ist auch ein ort
hier zu jeder zeit eine rakete
einschlagen kann mehrfach wurde auf
diese richtung bereits angegriffen und
die menschen die hier sind die kochen
für die soldaten und die soldaten die
hier sind müssen sich dann innerhalb von
30 sekunden in einen bunker flüchten und
dieser mann der gerade singt macht ihn
ein bisschen hoffnung in der schlimmsten
zeit die viele in ihrem leben jemals
erlebt haben eine hoffnung darauf dass
die hauptstadt anders als mario pohl
anders als party verschont bleiben
könnte aber das ist momentan nur eine
hoffnung es gibt keine zeichen darauf
dass sich wirklich etwas entspannt also
die leute denken sich hier absitzen
können wenn der angriff kommt wenn es
einen raketenangriff kommt dann muss man
rüber dort in einem der keller dieses
häuser dürfen wir nicht zeigen aus
sicherheitsgründen aber dort sind keller
da wir ändern frauen und kinder
reingebracht ganz schnell natürlich ist
auch dieser ort durch kann es stehe ein
target ein ziel wie die russische armee
denn hier sind die soldaten
wir werden soldaten also
[Musik]
die hauptstadt selbst ist immer noch in
ukrainischer hand anders sieht es in den
vororten chaos aus
dort in den vororten dort werden die
militärposten attackiert uns hat dort
ein soldat gesagt dass er heute morgen
eine eine attacke gab von russischer
seite auf diesen check point wir haben
gehört wie ein lagerhaus angegriffen
wurde mit drohnen und wir erleben wir
die menschen dort vor allem darauf
darüber nachdenken wie es ihnen
sozusagen passieren könnte also was in
den nächsten tagen passieren könnte wenn
die pille russische armee eingreifen
sollte man muss sich darauf einstellen
dass die krieg auch hier umkehrt immer
intensiver wird und wenn wir sehen was
in mario pohl passiert in diesen stunden
ich konnte gerade mit einem befreundeten
fotografen sprechen hat gesagt dass mein
freund ist es die hölle auf erden hier
in mariupol er sagte dass er keine
anrufe tätigen kann nur ab und zu kriegt
eine nachricht
ansonsten gibt es kaum kontakt also das
was dort passiert das ist die sorgen die
man ja auch in kiew brand ist etwas was
eventuell noch weitere städte und auch
auf
die angriffe nähern sich dem nato gebiet
in der nähe von lemberg nicht mal 50
kilometer von der polnischen grenze
entfernt schlagen russische raketen ein
das ist eine dramatische nach ich bin
die menschen dort denn das bedeutet dass
putin auch dort
terror anrichtet und dafür sorgt dass
möglicherweise noch mehr menschen raus
aus der ukraine friedberg der die
flüchtlings gute sozusagen noch voller
wird mit menschen denn es gibt keinen
sicheren ordner in der ukraine
in dem wohl am heftigsten beschossenen
vorort von kiew eröffnen die russen an
diesem tag das feuer auf us journalisten
wie heißt du who an woher kommst du aus
den usa und bist du okay ein bisschen
schwindelig aber mein freund ist
getroffen und dort zurückgeblieben
sein kollege der amerikanische
journalist brand renault bleibt vermisst
offenbar schwer getroffen durch
russischen beschuss
sein kollege horna redondo kann sich
ebenfalls angeschossen retten und wird
wenig später ins krankenhaus gebracht
sie waren zusammen an der front
unterwegs
iran jenseits der brücke in epping und
haben flüchtlinge gefilmt die das gebiet
gerade verließen und hat jemand
angeboten uns im auto mitzunehmen dann
sind wir an einem checkpoint
vorbeigekommen und dann fingen sie an
auf uns zu schießen also drehte der
fahrer um aber sie haben immer weiter
geschossen mein freund brand renault
wurde getroffen und es dort
zurückgeblieben
offenbar hatte es in scharf bitte geben
sie heute als auch gestern von
russischer seite das ist das was die
patina und berichten das ist schwer
sozusagen einzuordnen in dem moment aber
trennen ist es offenbar so das ist
weitere verletzte und möglicherweise
tote gab bei diesem vorfall und wir
jetzt recherchieren müssen was dort
genau passiert ist tatsache ist dass wir
auch und weite neben scharfschützen
immer wieder
artilleriefeuer gehört haben ebenfalls
in alpinen also die kämpfe dort die
kämpfe in der in dem vorort von hier die
geht unverändert weiter
brent renault wird schließlich tot
aufgefunden zwei weitere amerikanische
journalistin sterben am gleichen tag
durch russische kugel
es gibt berichte wonach ukrainische
soldaten angeblich die beiden gewarnt
haben sollen nicht weiter zu gehen das
ist aber wie gesagt noch unbestätigt es
ist immer eine abwägungsfrage gehe ich
diesen einen schritt noch weiter gehe
ich noch einen checkpoint weiter
versuche ich noch weiterzukommen das
muss man als journalist immer selbst
entscheiden nicht nur für sich selbst
sondern für das ganze team und das ist
durchaus eine große verantwortung ich
bin in großer trauer für den kollegen
für seine familie und mit großem respekt
vor allen kolleginnen und kollegen die
diesen krieg zeigen die zeigen was den
menschen passiert und ich glaube wenn
ich das persönlich sagen darf ich
versuche da nicht zu viel darüber
nachzudenken denn ich glaube das hält
man gar nicht aus angst zu sterben habe
ich keine ich glaube dann könnte man den
job hier nur schwer machen natürlich
habe ich respekt davor von dem was hier
angefahren lauert aber natürlich macht
man sich große gedanken und es sind
trauer wenn man sieht was in dieser
woche passiert ist und wie viele
journalisten hier bereits ums leben
gekommen sind
[Musik]
eine überwachungskamera filmt einen
raketeneinschlag mitten in kiew
der riesige krater zeigt die wucht der
detonation mindestens ein menschen
stirbt
ein weiterer chancen worden wir sehen
hier
bewusst mitten in der stadt zu sagen
wladimir und vitali klitschko sind wir
hier wir sehen hier ein weiteres aus was
betraut worden entbehrt dieser bus
hinter und das auch getroffen worden
das ist
nämlich spiegel zum glück genug weil er
weil er ist immer mehr gibt keine straße
ohne
position
ich will mir das sehen vitali hier wenn
wir diesen kater sehen dann sieht man ja
was was hier
passiert insgesamt in der stadt
so wallis zum erschießen extrem hart
geschlagen nur an militärobjekten dass
das tragen das ist eine wertanlage
gesehen das ist ein mittel
gegen zehn menschen
das vernichten von ukraine das
was das ist was passiert aber ich weiß
wie solche anschläge
rosenberg reserve eine beide kinder
unsere
wir gehen niemals im krieg wir sind
bereit und selbst zu bezahlen waren und
werden niemals cloud lieber sterben als
moritz graf ist dieser bombenkrater und
die explosion ausgelöst wurde und da
sind jetzt bereits
bereits aufräumarbeiten die hier
stattfinden und wir gehen noch mal ein
stück weiter einfach
wir gehen wir gehen hier noch mal ein
bisschen weiter
in die richtung ja ja wir werden jetzt
hier raus geschickt so zu sagen wir sind
ja eigentlich nur rein gekommen weil wir
das mit vitali und wladimir klitschko
unterwegs war sehr die journalisten
müssen eigentlich dort hinten stehen
und jetzt in diesem moment auf ab
[Musik]
was erwarte ich für diese nacht jetzt
hörst du es was wir leider hier erwarten
müssen weiteren beschuss in diesem
moment wieder raketenalarm wieder
sirenen die beginnen denn hier zu holen
und manchmal ist es so man hört diese
sirenen man hat sie so häufig gehört man
hört schon gar nicht mehr so richtig hin
und will sie ignorieren und wenige
stunden später passiert dann so etwas
was wir dort an dem appartement gebäude
gehört haben gesehen haben wo menschen
auch kurz vorher möglicherweise sirenen
gehört haben und minuten später sind
dann die raketen auf ihr haus geflogen
das heißt es kann jederzeit zu jeder
stunde überall passieren nicht nur hier
in kiew im ganzen land wir erwarten
erneut eine schlimme nacht für mario
pohl ein kollege von mir ein fotograf
den ich gut kenne mit dem ich unterwegs
waren kasachstan und in der ukraine der
ist dort eingeschlossen immer noch hat
kaum strom kein wasser kann bilder nur
dann schwer zeigen diesen wichtigen
bilder die er gemacht hat von der
geburtsklinik und es ist eine ja eine
schlimme katastrophe wir wollen hier
bleiben wollen berichten wollen weiter
für bild berichten und zeigen was hier
in kiew passiert paul selbst von hier
aus ein weit weg entfernt in berlin
läuft es einem eiskalt immer wieder den
rücken herunter wenn man diese ist
sirenengeheul in der dunklen nacht hört
und hinter dir vorhin gerade auch noch
ein orangenes aufleuchten was immer das
gewesen war dort in der ferne
ja wir gehen davon aus dass das
sicherlich beschuss war oder eine rakete
war
jj defizite
also das bestätigt dass es offenbar
irgendeine art von explosionen gegeben
hat hier hinter uns im hintergrund zu
sehen in dem moment wo wir hier gerade
live fahren wir haben jetzt erneut sie
reden und diesem moment
es ist thomas mann denkt und wo man
hofft obwohl man betet dass es endlich
friedenszeichen geben könnte immer
wieder so jeden tag dass menschen hier
ums leben kommen
paul passt gut auf euch auf danke
die folgen einer nacht voller
bombenalarme werden am nächsten morgen
sichtbar mehrere wohnhäuser in kiew sind
zerstört
[Musik]
weil wir
mittlerweile bestätigt informationen
wird mindestens zwei menschen ums leben
gekommen hier wurden die man schlagen
vor dem aufsichtsrat gegenüber am
frieden worden rufen sie und wie viele
vermisste dieser reise im garten
und heftig beklagen gemacht dass kinder
überhaupt noch als er
gegen aus dem hause gefertigt wurden
aber irgendwann zähler gesagt das aber
schon ausführlich das meisten menschen
wohl
laufen
genaue opferzahlen sind schwer zu
ermitteln in feuerpause bemühen sich
feuerwehr und armee um lösch und
aufräumarbeiten immer mehr teile der
hauptstadt gleichen trümmerfeldern
[Musik]
mario pohl die ostukrainische stadt
direkt an der küste sie ist das wohl am
stärksten umkämpfte gebiet der ukraine
am tag 21 bombardieren russische
einheiten das theater und das obwohl
über 1000 zivilisten genau dort schutz
suchen vor das gebäude hatten sie das
wort kinder in kyrillisch geschrieben
doch das hielt den gegner nicht davon ab
dass gebäude in schutt und asche zu
legen
die gesamte stadt ist von der
trinkwasser strom und
nahrungsmittelversorgung abgeschnitten
aber auch in der hauptstadt spitzt sich
die lage weiter zu auch wenn die ukraine
die wichtigsten stellungen weiter halten
können
kontrolliert die ausgangssperre die
theke gewähren deswegen wir mehr um
musik bereits die menschen tief und
deswegen bis morgen 7 noch führungskreis
der stunde wird das funktionieren
danach sehen wie die ganze person in
stattgefunden
hoffen wir dass wird bisschen leichter
feder worden was sich viele menschen
fragen wie halten die ukraine das auf
jeden tag neue angriffe wie haltet ihr
das aus wir halten die menschen das aus
mit diesem druck umzugehen zum beispiel
die vergessen angriffe als appartements
an wohnhäuser wurden lebten sie wie
listen nach birma angriff aber kann
menschen gesprochen wir sind gebiete zu
evakuieren
nachweis noch reine die menschen ich war
richtig überrascht
weil wir wollen nicht verpflichten wie
wie man hier bleibt wir wollen hier
bleiben zumeist und sogar die wende zu
mehr darum sagen dass es unsere stadt
leider unsere häuser unsere wohnung
zerstört aber wir werden hier bleiben
und unsere stadt zu verteidigen bitte
geben sie bitte an uns waffen das ist
eine zeichen statt
panik statt
depression dem menschen ist noch mehr
wichtig und bereit seine häuser seiner
familie seinen staatsbeteiligung also
diese april auch in deutschland in
diesem moment an den bundeskanzler dass
ihre mehr waffen unterstützung braucht
und auch die frage an dich wäre es ein
richtiges zeichen den olaf scholz auch
hier her käme wie der stadtpräsident
jeder der figur de der
wichtige politiker muss dabei sein muss
um auch eine unterstützung weil
gemeinsam mit den stark und gemeinsam
unter druck hoffen wir stoppte russland
oder vor zu notieren
ich schließe nicht aus dass es sein wird
eine
symbolisches ironische besuch aber die
noch genau sagen dass es ist ziemlich
gefährlich klare worte ganz zum schluss
war das immer wieder viele menschen in
deutschland fragen ihr bleibt richtig
hier bleibt wie bleiben wir bleiben wie
kann man keine andere wahl das ist
wo soll ich hin wir
bauen du hast meine wahl du bist ein
ausländer was machst du hier es ist
gefährlich für die hier aber wir sind
dankbar dass so wie du wir sind viele
journalisten und die journalisten die
gekillt worden ist seien zeichen weg von
hier isoliert ihm das blut und wasser
und um was das ist super das und was es
wichtig dass es wahrheit berichten als
wladimir klitschko mich gefragt hat
warum bist du denn noch hier da denkt
man natürlich kurz nach wenn so ein
großer boxer allen fragt mensch warum
was machst du noch hier sozusagen das
war aber glaub ich halb ernst gemeint
weil er weiß dass ich hier bleiben will
zumindest solange wie es geht und für
mich spielen der zwei dinge eine rolle
das eine ist dass reporter seien hier
vor ort und das gefühl zu haben dass es
wichtig ist dass reporter hier sind
gewisser weise auch als menschliche
schutzschilde sozusagen denn mein gefühl
ist wenn reporter hier sind dann ist es
vielleicht etwas besser als sonst wäre
auch die art wie der krieg geführt wird
das zweite neben dem reporter seien sind
meine persönlichen bindungen zu vielen
menschen in der ukraine zu den
klitschkos aber auch zu vielen anderen
freunden hier in der ukraine ich habe
viele reporter die ich kenne viele
menschen die ich kennengelernt habe seit
2013 und deswegen habe ich auch eine
besondere bindung
im land
raketeneinschläge gehören auch in kiew
inzwischen zur tagesordnung viele
straßen sind nicht mehr befahrbar
zivilisten gehen kaum noch auf die
straße
das stadtbild hat sich massiv verändert
auch noch mal in den letzten tagen wir
wissen ja heute zum beispiel hatte man
damit gerechnet erneut das ist eine
offensive geben könnte deswegen hat man
hier eine ausgangssperre verhängt für
den ganzen tag für den ganzen abend
morgen früh soll diese eigentlich wieder
aufgehoben werden das kann aber noch mal
auch verlängert werden wir sehen im
stadtbild immer mehr check points sind
hier auch nervöse hre soldaten dort
nervöse zivile verteidigung einheiten
und wir haben ganz viele anti panzer
minen dort gesehen die bereits offenbar
an diesen check points verteilt werden
für den fall dass es zum angriff kommt
dass dann die straße des checkpoint
komplett vermietet wird
ukrainerinnen nähen außerdem tarnnetze
aus bettlaken und seilen sie sollen die
satelliten systeme der russen
austricksen
ich habe noch nicht viele davon gesehen
aber einzelne die zum großen teil noch
nicht zuordnen zuordnung spa sind es ist
so so denke ich oder so höre ich auch
dass es hier viele dinge gibt die man
sich überlegt hat für den fall einer
invasion in das zentrum von kiew witali
klitschko der bürgermeister spricht
immer von vielen überraschungen für die
russischen soldaten
[Musik]
morgen des 17 märz spricht ein
besonderer gast per videoschalte vor dem
deutschen bundestag
es ist der ukrainische präsident
so erzeugt
ein ehemaliger schauspieler ein
präsident von vereinigten staaten ronald
reagan hat mal gesagt in berlin
er hat gesagt mister gorbatschow tear
down
zerstören sie diese mauer und das sage
ich an sie
lieber herr bundeskanzler scholz
zerstören sie diese mauer
gebe sie deutschland die führungsrolle
die sie die deutschland verdient und die
damit ihre nachfahren stolz sind auf sie
unterstützen sie den frieden
unterstützen sie die ukraine ich doch
diese sind krieg helfen sie uns diesen
krieg zu stoppen es lebe die ukraine im
anschluss stehende ovationen aber keine
antwort des bundeskanzlers keine
diskussion stattdessen geht das
parlament kommentarlos zur tagesordnung
über ja ich bin nur noch fassungslos
darüber wie der deutsche bundestag auf
den präsidenten reagiert hat ich hoffe
nur das motto müsse lenski das video
wirklich sofort ausgemacht hat als seine
rede vorbei war denn sonst hätte er das
gesehen was wir alle mit ansehen mussten
geburtstagswünsche nach so einer rede an
bundestagsabgeordnete nämlich an in dem
moment das muss man sich einmal
vorstellen aber es steht für mich auch
symbolisch dafür wie die deutsche
politik sich verhalten hat in den
vergangenen acht jahren immer wieder hat
man zwar zugehört man hat gelesen in
bild man hat gehört in anderen
nachrichtensendungen was die
ukrainischen politiker sagen aber man
hat nicht reagiert absolute
tatenlosigkeit und das was da gerade
passiert das steht symbolisch für das
wegducken und nichts tun gegen wladimir
putin da steht ein präsident vor dem
deutschen parlament
kritisiert rechnet ab mit der putin
politik gesagt warum macht die usa
eigentlich mehr als ihr verweist auf
unsere historische geschichte verweist
darauf dass badenia eine holocaust
denkmal bombardiert wurde und sagt was
ist mit den worten nie wieder die auch
in deutschland immer wieder gesagt
werden
und dann kommt die vize
bundestagspräsidentin und
gibt geburtstagswünsche ab also ich bin
sprachlos fassungslos
und selbst wenn das so geplant war
selbst wenn es eine tagesordnung gab ja
verdammt noch mal dann zerreißt diese
tagesordnung und seit menschlich und
antwortet auf einen ukrainischen
präsidenten der dort in einem bunker
sitzt der jede minute damit rechnen muss
getötet zu werden deren land verteidigt
der städte wie mario pohl verteidigt die
eingekesselt sind die tagesordnung in
deutschland sind geburtstagswünsche und
die tagesordnung in der ukraine ist der
tod
eine neue hiobsbotschaft die bisher
relativ sichere stadt lemberg im westen
der ukraine wird ziel der angriffe um
das flughafengelände herum kommt es zu
explosionen
es ist ja nicht das erste mal dass es
dort einen angriff gab bislang
beschränken sich diese an wofür
allerdings eben auf flughäfen auf diese
ziele da geht es denke ich auch sehr um
psychologie denn man möchte den westen
zeigen ihr seid dort nicht sicher wenn
ihr waffen liefert eure waffen die über
lemberg kommen deswegen versucht man
sozusagen auch dort ziele zu treffen das
macht ihr insofern sorgen als das
natürlich lemberg immer als der sichere
hafen noch hier galt der teil wo man als
flüchtling hin kann wo man aus kiew
hinfliegen kann aus den vororten
entfliehen kann und wenn das so weiter
gehen sollte mit den angriffen also wenn
das sich verstärken sollte dann könnte
das für eine riesengroße
flüchtlingswelle hier raus aus der
ukraine
auch in anderen teilen des landes gehen
die angriffe weiter in hk versteht der
größte freiluft markt osteuropas in
flammen
in kiew werden ebenfalls zivile ziele
bombardiert
sich das so vorstellen das sind mario
pohl 80 prozent des stadtbildes so
aussieht wie hier gerade in kiew wenn
wir vielleicht noch einmal die häuser
dort zeigen die x wohnungen waren also
wirklich unfassbare bilder die man hier
auch nicht aus dem kopf bekommt und so
sieht 80 prozent von mario pohl momentan
aus 80 prozent von mario pohl sieht so
aus wie dieses schlachtfeld in kiew und
das ist so muss man sich vorstellen
tatsächlich etwas was die russische
armee hier an richtig wahrnehmen uns
doch noch mal ein kleines stückchen mit
zeigt uns noch mal was tatsächlich dort
angerichtet wir gehen einmal ins
bombosch mit ihr lassen durch diese
gegen und sehen hier zum beispiel ein
auto muss das gewesen sein was in schutt
und asche gelegt wurde vor allem sieht
man die ganze kraft
dieser
raketen wie weit
sie gehen und wie weit dieser angriff
war und es ist tatsächlich ein wunder
selbst hier diese wohnungen wurden noch
zerstört und man muss sich das
vorstellen
von dieser seite dorthin also diese
ganze wucht eines raketenangriffs wird
hier auf diesen platz deutlich
und man muss davon ausgehen
dass die meisten menschen hier diesen
platz schon verlassen hatten bzw
ihre wohnung verlassen haben denn anders
ist es nicht zu erklären dass es in
anführungszeichen nur einen toten gab
bei dieser wucht der explosion
allerdings noch einmal mindestens 19
verletzt wir wissen nicht wie schwer und
vier davon kinder auch in dieser
richtung ist eine schule das sieht man
jetzt nicht so ganz genau eine schule
untergebracht auch dort zerstörung und
wir gehen einfach hier nochmal ein stück
weiter weil wir denken ist es wichtig
dass deutschland diese dimension dieses
angriffs sieht schaut euch an was hier
passiert ist unfassbar
[Musik]
auch wenn dieser krieg ganz anders läuft
als putin sich das vorgestellt hat fest
steht auch es gibt keinen einzigen
sicheren ort mehr in der gesamten
ukraine
eines kann ich ihnen versprechen meine
kollegen und ich werden weiter aus der
ukraine berichten weiter aus der
hauptstadt hier in kiel weiter aus
lemberg und der gesamten ukraine
denn unser job ist es unsere aufgabe ist
es ihnen zu zeigen welche fürchterlichen
konsequenzen jeans bomben auf die
ukraine wirklich hart